we've been covering for you for months
now the most transparent administration
in American history which stopped for 41
days giving press briefings altogether
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is Donald Trump's
press secretary and she has been giving
fewer and fewer press briefings over
time and up until yesterday it had been
41 days since the last one and all of
the normal stuff that we've become
accustomed to at these gongshow press
briefings took place and I wouldn't be
shocked if we don't hear from her again
for a very very long time not answering
questions blaming Democrats for
everything and generally speaking making
a fool out of herself coming out and
speaking after I think it was Steven
minuchin and Larry Kudlow and maybe one
other person who spoke before her
speaking to the press out comes Sarah
Huckabee Sanders starts getting asked
very reasonable questions like for
example we have this three-week stopgap
measure which reopened government from
petrol money for the wall does Trump
want another shutdown starting on
February 15th and her answer is it's the
fault of Democrats is the president
really willing to go through another
shutdown if you can't get any money into
Democrats or the boardwalk the president
doesn't want to go through another
shutdown that's not the goal the goal is
were security I'm protecting the
American people
ideally Democrats would take these next
three weeks to negotiate in good faith
as they've indicated that they would and
come up with a deal that makes sense
that actually fixes the problem so we
don't have to go through that process so
what she's saying is Trump had the House
and the Senate for two years during a
supposed at immigration crisis that was
going on then because it was worse than
the now if it's a crisis now it had to
have been a crisis then did nothing to
build the wall Democrats take the house
back and now Trump says either Democrats
fix this problem or I shut down the
government it's absolute and total joke
it's a farce next question the stuff
that Trump offered to Democrats in that
second crazy immigration speech remember
when he said I will do 3 years of
extension on daca recipient status I
will do 3 years
extension on TPS temporary protected
status reasonable question from the from
the press is that still on the table
Trump offered it is it still on the
table for Democrats
Sarah Huckabee Sanders won't say made in
this immigration speech are those still
on the table look I'm not going to
negotiate here that's why they have the
conference's for congressional members
to work through some of those things to
come back to the president with the deal
the president has laid out things in the
past that he's willing to do we'll see
what they come back with but what I do
know is if they don't come back with a
deal that means Democrats get virtually
nothing
so first answer was it's the fault of
Democrats and they need to fix this then
the question is is Trump's offer still
on the table she won't say but she again
says it's up to Democrats to figure this
out or they get nothing and then it gets
brilliant in the sense of being evil
genius Sarah Huckabee Sanders is asked
why did Trump hire undocumented
immigrants at his businesses and of
course there is no good answer for that
other than to just tell the truth which
is this is what companies do people like
Trump and corporations hire undocumented
immigrants and they don't get in trouble
so obviously they're going to keep
hiring undocumented immigrants check out
what she says truly orwellian described
illegal immigration objective
immigration as a peerless threat and
said that they're taking American
workers jobs you explain why the
president hired an employee as somebody
undocumented we're going to tennis club
for years that do do more to prevent
them from being employed and working
there look I can't get into specifics
about the president's organization
outside of the White House and only
allowed to speak on behalf of the
president in his official capacity I do
know that the Trump Organization has put
out a statement addressing that issue I
would refer you to that into them for
further questions
president thing should happen to a
business that you know employ illegal
immigrants and doesn't use systems to
check and make sure that I do it laughs
that's one of the reasons that the
president wants to actually fix the
problem he's one of the people that's
identified the fact that we have a
problem and we should fix our
immigration system if Democrats want to
get serious about fixing that they have
a president that's more than happy to
sit down with them and do exactly that
yeah hey the president's company hired
undocumented immigrants what about that
in what should happen to those companies
listen Trump identified this problem
I guess she means by being part of the
problem and if Democrats want to fix it
then Democrats can fix it and he'll
allow them to do that it's evil genius
it's just uh it's it's completely vapid
in every sense and I need to
congratulate CNN and MSNBC they didn't
air this ok Fox News ran the press
briefing live CNN and MSNBC just stuck
to the regular programming and I've been
saying for a while if you can't fact
check it live since it's so wild run it
later condensed with fact-checking even
do a five-minute delay so you can do
fact checking on on screen I think that
there's more going on here then she's
just a liar and an obfuscator
I actually think part of the reason
she's not answering questions is I don't
know that Trump is really speaking to
Sarah Huckabee Sanders anymore I
actually think she doesn't know what
Trump is thinking and what from
positions are on a lot of these issues
and remember we were told the most
transparent administration in history
that ship has certainly long sailed let
me know your thoughts about this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show i am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blink as' our audience can get
a 7 day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /p a que ma n